Welcome everyone, good afternoon,
my name is Elissa Strome,
I'm the executive director
of the Pan-Canadian AI strategy at CIFAR
and also the Associate
Vice President research.
And, it's my pleasure
to welcome you all today
to CIFAR's webinar
on science is the exit strategy.
This is a new series of
webinars that we're offering
to share with our community
research that's going on by
CIFAR researchers fellows,
Canada CIFAR AI chairs in Canada
and around the world to share
how science and science
based decision making
can be used and is being
used by governments
to help us think about how
we can reopen the economy,
(mumbles) in the wake of COVID-19.
If you're not familiar with us,
CIFAR is a Canadian based
global charitable organization,
and we convene extraordinary minds
to address the most important questions,
facing society and humanity.
Like many others across the globe,
CIFAR has pivoted quickly
to take action on COVID-19
and we've done a lot of
work in the last nine weeks
to mobilize researchers across
Canada and around the world
to help them and support them,
advance research on COVID.
What I'd like to do today
to kick off is introduce you
to two researchers that
we work with at CIFAR.
Marzyeh Ghassemi is a
Canada CIFAR AI chair
at the Vector Institute
and Assistant Professor at
the University of Toronto
where she also holds a
Canada Research Chair.
Her work focuses on applying machine,
learning to understand and improve health.
Joseph Paul Cohen, is
a Postdoctoral Fellow
with Yoshua Bengio at Mila in Montreal,
and at the University of Montreal.
His work examines the
applications of AI in medicine
with respect to computer vision,
genomics, clinical data, et cetera.
So Marzyeh and Joseph
have a new collaboration
that has emerged as a result of COVID-19
and then thinking,
collaboratively about how
they can work together
to address some of these issues.
Their project will use AI
to develop approaches
to understanding COVID-19
based on chest X-rays
and so we're gonna explore
and other types of medical imaging
so we're gonna explore their
project a little bit more.
Before we begin, though,
just a few sort of housekeeping issues,
the session today will last
for approximately 30 minutes
and I'm gonna sort of
kick off the conversation,
but then we'll open up
the floor for questions.
So we would love for the audience
to send in your questions,
please use the Q&A function,
and not the chat function
cause we'll be sort of monitoring,
your questions that come in through Q&A
and we'll make sure that
we save plenty of time
for those questions.
And lastly, I just
wanna let everybody know
that the session is being recorded.
So if you wanna go back
and look at it later
or send it along to your friends,
we'll have it up on the CIFAR website,
early next week.
Okay, so let's begin.
Marzyeh and Joseph, thank
you for joining us today
to share your work
and to be part of this conversation.
Let's start, Joseph
by talking a little bit
about the work that you did
last year you built a
platform called Chester
sort of, ironically named.
An AI, chest X-ray
radiology assistant tool
that your team develops,
and now you're pivoting
and thinking about how to
apply some of that work,
and the knowledge and
tools that you created
towards COVID-19.
And so, the first step in
your project with Marzyeh
is to build a public dataset
of chest X-ray, CT images
maybe other medical images as well.
And so, how are you guys
going about doing that?
What are the steps you're taking?
And, what are some of the
challenges that you're facing?
- Yeah so, initially we
had this Chester tool
and it already predicted pneumonia,
given datas that existed before
from like the NIH,
MIT, Stanford.
And, we wanted to see does this work
on the COVID pneumonia cases.
Is it able to offer an assistance there
and we looked around for
what data to try this on,
we couldn't find any.
And we contacted a bunch of groups
and it seems very difficult
to get data from hospital groups.
They're all so very busy
and hospitals that aren't busy,
don't have any data yet,
or it didn't have any data at that time.
So was really difficult
to get a handle on all this data,
and it seems like the,
infrastructure in the hospitals was not,
able to get us this data.
There was no infrastructure in place
to allow researchers access to
data as it's happening, right?
So this was unfortunate
for us there.
But we found that
journals journal publications,
did have these images in them.
Researchers were publishing
like one or two patients at
a time in these publications,
and then publishing them,
these high resolution
or CEP kind of high
resolution digital images
on the journal web pages
of like radiology, (mumbles).
So, in these online publications,
we can access a digital version
that's actually pretty high
resolution compared to what
these models were trained on
because we would resize them
to be pretty small images like,
224 by 224 resolution images.
The images on these websites
were thousands but thousands, right?
So, we had like a
sevision resolution there.
So we just started
aggregating these images
into a data set we could work with
by manually going to each web page,
downloading the image,
and then reading the
publication and finding,
the different kind of clinical outcomes,
and the different attributes
about these patients
that were already published there.
And this was really
good for us because the,
the ethics and consent,
were already taken care of
before this paper was published, right?
So that made it very
easy to work with as in,
in inside the ethical framework
of the University of Montreal,
cause it's this is this,
if it's already public
and it's already had all this consent on
we can use it,
so we can get going right out the gate
with all these images, right?
So this allowed us to start
building up this dataset,
which is now,
we now have hundreds
of frontal chest X-rays
from different patients, right?
With multiple time points.
- Great
and even around the world I guess too.
- Yeah, all over the,
which is a good way to
validate these models,
because we don't wanna
just have one hospital
that could have a,
an artifact that makes it
just work there but not other places,
we can really, test tools,
this way which has been
often how this data set has now been used
by a few groups
where they have their own
internal data set that they make.
And then when they actually
go to validate their model,
but they do it on an internal data set
to really prove it'll work
cause they can have a balanced cohort
that's like nice and randomly sampled.
But then, they can
publicly use the data that we put together
to demonstrate that their
model's working, right?
So this has been good
and beyond publications
we're also looking at
these repositories that exist.
There's a EURORAD system
which has been phenomenal as a resource,
because their licensing
is very clear for us to
use for research.
So these different repositories
that have been put up
that are, they're kind of silos themselves
of this COVID chest X-ray cases, right?
So they're, not only do
they have chest X-rays,
they have CT slices.
Some of them have CT's,
like full CT volumes.
So this is this massive data
that's tucked in all
these different systems
all over the world.
And in, where we've been
slowly putting it together
into this data set,
and then from the small data set,
we can start training these models.
- So it sounds like it's a
very labor intensive effort
just to even build the data set,
in order to be able to
build the models and then,
go on further and do research.
- Yeah, it's very hard to
build automatic scrapers.
We've had some,
some automation in this.
We just, we got some good results
on our EURORAD automatic scraper
so we can scrape a bunch of the,
detailed like the images,
we can get them
properly scraped with some basic metadata.
But, clinical outcomes
really hard to scrape from,
from natural text
that radiologists are writing
because you don't know
if it says that they,
tested for COVID and it was negative,
or that they tested
for COVID and it was positive, right?
So that the way it's
worded can be just wild
so, the best thing is to
just have a human reader.
So we've been doing that.
And we have dedicated students and,
like people looking at these things.
And I've spent a lot of time,
staring at these reports and,
learning a lot about,
I feel like, you really,
learn more about the disease
by reading a (mumbles) bunch of case notes
from doctors all over the world,
which scared me a lot, so,
just reading these case stories,
are very, sometimes sad.
- It brings it home a little bit,
makes it a little more real, right?
Great.
- Oh.
- Okay, so Marzyeh,
I know that a key
objective of your project
is to develop some new
machine learning algorithms
in order to be able to
analyze these machine,
these medical images
that you're aggregating
across many many different sources.
And so, what like,
why and how is that challenging?
What were some of the
challenges that you face?
And, like, particularly
from the fact that these
images are being compiled
from so many different sources
in different modalities,
in different languages,
maybe the case notes are
what are some of the
challenges that you have
in actually developing the AI tools
once you got the data set together?
- I think there are a couple of things
that make this very challenging.
I think that the,
the first thing
to sort of keep in mind is.
We know from work at NeurIPS,
one of the large machine
learning conferences
this past year,
in December of 2019
that medical image statistics
don't follow natural
image statistics, right?
So, one of the reasons
that convolutional neural
networks are so efficient
at doing object detection
or classification,
or any of the other many tasks that they,
they work fantastically well on
is because there are these
natural image statistics,
and there are things
that you can assume in many cases,
about this modality, right?
So if two things are close in
pixel space, right?
They're either close in real life,
or there's a border there, right?
And those kinds of
assumptions don't work in,
imaging modalities,
in the same way, right?
Because it's not actually
just a natural image.
And so, we know that
there are differences in how
you may want to fine-tune,
or take pre-trained deep neural networks
and apply them to medical imaging,
so that's its own
challenge in its own right.
There's also a lot of,
uncertainty about differences and
severity of cases,
and also labels for cases, right?
So, one of the projects that,
one of the postdocs in
my group was looking at,
she's looking at these labels
that are shared
and in some cases not shared
between large chest
X-ray imaging data sets
so these are data sets
that are put out by MIT
by Stanford,
by the NIH.
And they have some overlap,
in some of the clinical labels
that are assigned to the images,
but it's not complete so,
some places will label for
a particular condition
a pneumothorax
and others we won't.
And this also reflects differences
in what those actual care
centers tend to specialize in
and the populations that
they see in general.
So those I think those are
very challenging because again,
when we develop models in,
the natural world for things like
object detection.
We know object detection is important
because humans do it.
It's a task that humans do.
And we know that a dog
is a dog is a dog, right?
We can argue about
what breed of dog
and how old the dog is,
but we all agree
that this is a dog, right?
And, you could take, an untrained human,
not a specialist,
not somebody who has gone to
medical school for a decade,
and every untrained human will agree
that this is a dog, right?
But you can have two expert radiologists
who have gone to school for decades,
and they will disagree
about the label that should be assigned
to this image.
So this is also incredibly challenging
for machine learning
models to operate under.
And then, finally,
one of the things that's
really challenging,
specifically in this setting,
is that this is a novel condition.
And that's something that we're trying to
wrap our heads around
in terms of how to do
what is called few shot,
meaning I see a few examples,
and then I'm quickly able to generalize
or zero shot.
Meaning, I've not seen any examples
of this particular condition
but I'm able to detect
it as a new condition.
And these are specific
regimes in machine learning,
but they're often
when you use these specific regimes
often it's in very controlled environments
where you promise that you'll
only show the algorithm
five classes during its training
and its learning phase.
And then when you show it new things,
you'll show it only new things,
but none of you won't
evaluate it on the old things
that it might have forgotten, right?
And this is not a,
and so many of the evaluations
that are present in these sort of
larger learning scenarios don't apply here
because we don't want to
show a model many
examples of a pneumothorax
and of a hernia, all
these different things,
a fracture and then show it,
some COVID examples and
then have it forget.
Well what does a fracture look like?
I don't remember.
Additionally, we have these
multiple labels, right?
When you have one X-ray image
you could have a fracture,
and pneumonia,
that's possible, right?
And so, you have these
multiple labels that are toggled on,
but very rarely is
one object multiple objects.
It's not both a dog
and a cat, right?
You don't have cat dogs
that are coming around.
And so, I think there are all of these
technical challenges,
where you can't just
take off the shelf models
or tools, algorithms
that have been developed
because they're often
developed in a setting
again for natural images mostly
where we don't have any
of these constraints
and so there's been a lot
of work between the students
and the postdoc that Joseph and I
are co-supervising
to try to understand how we can,
modify a lot of these meta learning,
few shot learning, zero
shot learning algorithm
so that they work in this setting.
- Yeah, I think what strikes me
from how you've described it is that,
COVID-19 is an entirely new phenomenon
that we haven't seen before.
So the old models, you
can't just apply them
we have to really think about
how do we modify them for
this particular circumstance.
- I think it's also,
it's unclear for something
like COVID-19, right?
How different it should be, for example,
in this one modality,
in chest X-rays from pneumonia,
very severe pneumonia, right?
And so, we know
that in a lot of early cases for example,
in China and Iran,
you would have COVID-19 cases
that were diagnosed as
just typical pneumonia.
Right?
- Right.
- Which led to high
mortality rates initially.
And so, it's unclear
whether in this one modality
just looking at chest X-rays
without any additional information,
whether we would be able
to detect a big difference that,
just one snapshot we're
not seeing any progression,
we're not seeing anything else.
Between a pneumonia case
and a COVID-19 case, right?
And so, that's why it's so important that,
Joseph and his team have been working
to collect other indicators,
along with just this image, right?
So that we can see for example,
maybe it's not a one snapshot
that you're given
without any context that's important.
Maybe you have to see some metadata,
maybe you have to see some progression.
- Right?
And so, there's a lot of research,
there's a lot that we're
gonna learn about COVID
and its impact on people and
their health hopefully
through this project.
So you guys have both
alluded to this a little bit.
I wanna talk a little bit
about the fact that this is a,
a new collaboration between
your two research groups.
So we've got a research
team at the Vector Institute
supervised by Marzyeh,
we've got a research
team at Mila in Montreal
supervised by Joseph.
And, you've organized yourselves
looking at different objectives
and different projects,
tell us a little bit more about the,
the team of people behind the scenes
that are really at the front lines doing,
the day to day aspects of this research.
- Well I think we have a,
we have a bunch of students
that are, oh,
specifically I guess a Carsten
who's between both teams right now
so he's at Vector but,
where he used to be at Mila
so he's really bridging the
gap between these two groups.
So I think that's a,
it's good for both labs in general,
to have that cross pollination there.
Medical student, (mumbles) who's,
we were working on evaluating Chester
in some educational settings.
And then we've shifted now to focus on,
on how do we make this,
help treat the COVID cases, right?
So, in terms of
figuring out with the,
the radiology and medical community,
like that they want
severity prediction, right?
And also looking at the
trajectories of patients.
So, figure isolating those specific cases
have been has been very, have been very,
has been very useful.
And, I think it's a great opportunity
for people that we have
working from medical backgrounds
to really look at the
computational side of all this
and how we can assist
these things
with collaborators at,
at Stony Brook students
there are working on,
on running these tools
that we're building to
kind of really analyze
what they can do,
what they can tell,
and inform these medical professionals,
and how that's gonna
actually get into their
clinical workflow, right?
At what point does the
decision get be made?
And, their insights into how that
these tools like if they can span the gap,
span this,
the sarcasm between the two fields, right?
How can that workflow be disrupted by
these medical tools, right?
So it's just like an iterative process
that has to keep going
and we need to make better tools better,
but I think getting that feedback
from students that that's
span this boundary is very important.
- So critical when we're,
computer scientists and used to,
a certain way of working
and a certain way of thinking
and a certain jargon,
to work directly with the clinicians
who are at the front lines and,
they know what tools and
resources and insights
that they need you to help them
find out that the data,
but also really helpful to hear from them
with their experiences and how,
AI can really help them
in the course of their
treatment of patients.
Marzyeh, tell us a little
bit about your team.
- So the team that I have here,
the way that they sort of percolated is,
I had a postdoc,
so an INSDOC postdoctoral fellow
who was working in my lab previously.
And then, I had invited Joseph
to come and give a talk,
in my class.
So I have a machine learning
for health graduate course
that's taught in the
Department of Computer Science.
And I wanted him to come and give a,
a lecture on medical imaging
and he came and the students loved him.
They thought he did a
really fantastic job.
And so, he and he also
had a chance to meet with
some of my students while he was visiting
the Vector Institute,
and he had a chance to
meet with my postdoc
and after he had gone, my postdoc,
Lala Li said, he's great
like it was really
helpful chatting with him.
And so, she and I had been talking
outside of the context of
COVID completely independently,
before this all hit.
We had a project where we were looking at,
and this paper is posted to Archive.
So, we're looking at the differences
in classification rates
in chest X-ray images
amongst people of different ethnicities,
different genders,
in United States of
different insurance types.
And so there's a lot of exclusion,
and there's a lot of difference
in how accurate machine
learning models are
when you train state of the art models
and how accurate they are
in classifying people of different again,
genders, ethnicities and insurance types
on these standard tasks,
and some of this is just because
we have under representation, right?
In these data sets that's
the way that it is.
And so, she and I had done
this project previously,
which is currently under review,
but also posted on Archive,
if you go on to read it.
And then as she had spoken
to Joseph about this,
and we were talking about
ways to fix this, right?
So we've established that
there is this problem,
we'd really like to fix it.
And so then, COVID happened.
And, we discussed with Joseph
really what we wanna fix
is this classification problem,
wouldn't it be nice if we
were thinking about it in this
robustness sense, right?
Not just from a bias perspective
but just from overall robustness.
And so, she's led a lot of this
on my team side
and then Joseph and I talked about
how we really and so Joseph has been
on all our weekly team calls
for a month and a 1/2 now, right?
Like going through
all of the planning for this project,
but then Joseph and I had discussed
we wanted to have an
additional student, right?
Somebody who really could
do the extra bridging
because Lala was sort of
part of my team previously,
and Joseph has some students
who are part of his team previously
so we wanted this additional person
who could help with the bridging
and that is this student Carsten
who's fantastic,
and we've been meeting with
for the past two weeks
since his onboarding.
And I think it's,
it is really important
to have a mixture of,
people from both sides, right?
So both people who,
have experience in different
kinds of machine learning,
experience in on the clinical side,
in trying to understand how you might
scrape things best,
how you might label things best,
when there's a discrepancy
between different sources of information,
which one you should rely upon more.
So I think that that
has been very helpful.
- That's so great and I love the idea of,
having somebody who bridges both teams
in these times when we
can't meet face to face
and we have to meet virtually
having somebody who's going back and forth
and interacting and really,
seeing both sides of the project,
very deeply it's so helpful
to sort of keep everybody together.
Okay, so we're gonna move to
some audience questions now
and I've got a good one.
Here that's come in.
And so it reads, Joseph mentioned
that a clear licensing policy is helpful
when attempting to use
a publicly available image data set.
Could you speak a bit
more about the features
of a good licensing policy?
What challenges do you face
with licensing policies?
- Yeah so, with a lot of datasets,
there are very ambiguous licenses
that they have.
So, for a subset of the data set we have,
that's come from EURORAD
and radiopaedia which I really wanna
shout out to their groups
because that their licensing
is a Creative Commons,
Non-commercial Share Alike license,
which is just great for,
the people wanna contribute
to do public research, right?
So, a non commercial
license makes everyone happy
with that arrangement, right?
Because if there's commercial interest
this can make people
more hesitant to share.
So having that non commercial
license is fine for,
for doing research (mumbles).
And then there's been a new data release
that came over from Hannover
University in Germany,
this is just like a few days ago.
And we just discussed with them
and they want to contribute their data
to merge it into our data set but that
they're gonna have
continually do data releases,
and they did like a
creative commons, share
alike, I think yeah
so is just a creative commons share alike.
There's no non commercial restrictions
it's even more open
than the existing data we had,
which is really great.
So I think,
it just makes it easy to do anything
with this data set.
And I think that's,
really an enabling license.
Actually, the licenses are more
for the enabling aspect of it.
And then, for the epitome of
of open datasets,
there's the NIH data set,
which we can all like,
run up summers, tell us it's 17
kinda completely like broke up
in the entire field of digital
or AI radiology right,
with this data set.
It had a.
It's like a public domain license,
so there's no, there's no,
it's very clear what you can do with it,
you can do anything, right?
And this has enabled us
to make derivatives of it,
and really like a Google
has built a new data set,
which is based on that data set
and just relabeled it
and then release that as a derivative work
and this is a, been a,
it's really it's a highly act
like highly accurate really specialized
data set so like,
these derivative works
are the result
of a really good clear license, right?
That makes everyone happy
with that situation
and feel more confident
that they're not gonna
have to take down this
derivative work after
they released it, right?
And we can already see it happening
with the data set that
we've released, right?
Given the ability for groups
to add annotations on top,
and then release that as
a subsequent work, right?
So we've had a group that's
annotated the lung regions.
- Nice.
- As bounding boxes
and release that
with the, with,
sorry, it's now in our repository
released alongside our data
so they've kind of labeled a subset.
We're in discussion with other people
that are gonna do even more fine grained
segmentations on the data we have, right?
And I think that they're doing that
because this data is open
in the first place, right?
So I think that that,
so the clear licensing makes it
easy for everyone to work with
and use
for their different purposes, right?
- Yeah, I mean,
we know how critical
data is the foundation
of what we do in AI.
We couldn't do any of this without
large, very accessible,
very good data sets,
so, so important to have
access to them.
And I love what you've just
described Joseph about how,
the fact that they're open
means that other people
are doing more and bigger
and other interesting things with them
and in fact it becomes,
a global collaboration
when you're thinking
about how other people
are making derivatives and adding on
to the work that you're doing
it really makes a very strong case
for continuing around, open science.
Okay, so we have another
question, that's come in.
Marzyeh, one question that
came in from the audience was,
they're wondering
if there are any applications
on your AI based approach
that can help to inform
the development of new
treatments for COVID-19?
- I think it's hard to know
what this could be extended to.
In terms of treatments,
one of the things that
has been really hard to hear
from a lot of the local
hospital specialists
that I collaborate with on other projects
but are now sort of overwhelmed
with COVID-19 treatment is that,
many of our most intensive treatments
are not working consistently, right?
So there's been
a lot of anecdotal reports,
but now several reports coming out
of other locations that
were hit much harder, right?
So this is out of China, out of Italy,
out of Iran, out of New York.
That mechanical ventilation
is not working consistently.
And that some of the
pre-existing conditions
that you might have assumed
would have led to really,
really poor responses so
comorbidities like asthma.
They are not, right?
And so, I think that it's possible
that a better detector,
a better classifier for early screening,
especially as we start
to have conversations
in North America about opening up.
What that means for summer
what that means for the fall,
whether there will be second waves
that come in.
I think it opens up the ability
to have more,
maybe quicker screening
or more physically distant screening,
lower cost screening
for particular populations.
So I think it can lead
to a better understanding
and characterization.
I think there's a lot of very good work
on the bio-chemistry side
being led by people like
Regina Barzilay at MIT
or Alan Aspuru-Guzik (mumbles)
University of Toronto,
who are trying to figure
out exactly what's happening
with specific drugs or treatments.
- Great, thanks for that.
We have time for just one more question
reading lots of questions
coming in from the audience.
So lots of interest in
this topic in this project.
One more question, maybe
for the both of you.
How do you balance the need
for fast growing research
and pre-print publication,
with the rigor and peer review
during the pandemic, right?
So, we wanna get our results out
we wanna share with the world.
But it's not the same thing
as a peer reviewed publication.
So, how do you balance that guys?
- So, I think.
Nothing should change,
because why were we not being critical
about the papers in the past,
we just blindly trusted
the peer review.
- Right.
- Yeah.
So I think,
if a paper is hard to understand,
and therefore, and for that reason,
you can't like believe that it's right
cause you don't understand the
entire experimental protocol,
then don't trust the paper right like,
why should peer review
allow someone else to tell you,
you should trust that (mumbles)
just more work to filter
these papers yourselves,
you should always be doing this
with every paper that (mumbles).
- And so how important is it right now
to get your results out
in the pre-prints world?
- I think it's becoming
increasingly apparent
that the, the style of
early release of results,
that is, I should say in different
academic communities
have very different ways
that they tend to push results out
and the machine learning
community for a while now
has had a culture
of publishing a pre-print
on a service like Archive.
And then, as it is undergoing peer review.
And then, you may see for
example this is common,
I just wanna emphasize
how common this is that,
a paper is posted in September
of 2018 on Archive.
It is submitted somewhere
and doesn't make it into
that particular machine
learning conference, right?
Unlike many of the journals where
there's this, year long back and forth
where well, edit did
this, cite this, add this,
you have this one shot, that is,
mildly stochastic, right?
Depends on what reviewers you get.
You often don't have a rebuttal
in some of these conferences
and so you might submit to NeurIPS
and it doesn't get into NeurIPS.
And so, that's fine,
we say like re-roll, right?
You submit essentially the same paper
with some corrections or clarifications
as recommended by the reviewers
to ICML
or to if it's more data
sensors focus to KDD to,
wherever you're submitting it to, right?
So I don't think that
culture should change.
I'm happy that other publishing cultures
are coming more in line with that.
I think that that puts significantly more
a much higher expectation
of rigor on the PI.
So my students,
one of my previous students
really wanted to Archive their work,
because they felt some pressure
and I told the student it's not ready.
And they said why it's not peer reviewed,
it's just Archive
and I said no like this is.
- (mumbles) Ready to go, yeah.
- It has to be ready to go.
This has to pass my sniff test
because it has our names on it
and it means that
we're putting this out
there for consumption
and you don't want to mislead people.
And so, I think that it
shifts the burden from a
well let's just throw
this out to peer review
we'll see if they spot a mistake,
to saying like,
this is an academic product
that I am approving
as I think this is good
enough to go out there.
- Thank you so much to both of you
for sharing your insights on your project
and also the inner workings
of the machine learning community,
the academic (mumbles),
and the research and publishing community.
We are over time I have to
apologize to our audience
for going a little bit over time
but the conversation was so interesting.
I wanted to let everybody know that
this is a series that CIFAR is offering
and we have another webinar (mumbles)
coming up for June 4th
with a fellow in our
humans in the micropo,
humans in the microbiome program.
His name is Professor Hendrik Poinar,
he's from McMaster University
and he's gonna talk about
what makes this pandemic,
he's an evolutionary geneticist,
he gonna talk about what
makes this pandemic,
different and what we can
learn from past pandemics
to inform us about what
we know about COVID-19
so should be very interesting.
And we hope that you can join us then.
So please visit our website,
cifar.ca to find out more about
the upcoming webinars,
we'll have the video for
this one posted next week
and we'll look forward
to seeing you again.
Thanks once more to Marzyeh and Joseph.
Bye-bye.